vim falar criatividade e associar a
energia é algo fácil por exemplo para
sermos criativos basta pensarmos um
objeto estranho como uma corda que
normalmente tem duas pontas que é que
torna diferente é quando essa mesma hora
nas duas pontas tem dois meios e uma
corda com duas pontas e dois meses é um
objeto um pouco criativo
eu sei que estou a pensar ok mas eu vou
tornar ainda mais criativa transformá la
numa corda com quatro pontas porque
agora quatro pontos já justificavam a
ter 20 mais criativa ainda uma corda com
quatro pontos e só tem um meio tão aqui
algum momento influência das cordas
habituais mas nós cubanos efetivamente
em duas dessas pontas charles e
mostramos desde o início que o que nós
temos são de facto escolas justificam a
existência das duas contas do seu meio
chato quando nós associada criatividade
mostramos que na verdade temos uma corda
quando as pontas e um meio e aqui sim já
qualquer coisa de frente que estão
habituados a ver uma coisa muito
criativo é que fazer com uma corda com
duas pontas dilma e faz um experimento
em dar um nó no meio da copa sem pagar
as contas
é estranhíssimo para isso teve sua
mochila é fantástico nunca largar nas
pontas e conseguirmos de facto ter o nó
mais ou menos a meio da cola governo
então não vocês vão ver uma corda poeta
nós criamos apresentará como química
ligações químicas jatos moléculas que
fosse mas na verdade desde o início
o que nós temos é uma corda com duas
pontas e poderia ter dois
sim mas este é o momento
a liga é o facto vai falar do que
experimentemos conseguir comunicar
ciência o ensino formal da ciência
ocorrendo organismo é ao facto surgiu
naturalmente no percurso que temos vindo
a fazer de facto como digo mas dizia nós
verificamos como nos dizer se existe
esta estas emoções
este boa disposição principalmente e
está associada a alguém não se sabe como
é que acontece é tanto nosso imaginário
cria imediatamente teorias mas o que é
isso senão a ciência das ciências facto
é verdadeira magia porque o fato mostra
situações que nós muitas vezes não
percebemos
mas o que se procura explicar as
mostradas vertical aceitar produzidas em
laboratório
então como homem da ciência verifiquei
que o senhor sociais a energia
a explicação com 7 ciência conseguimos
chegar mais fácil mais fortemente me
alimentar combinava jovem que começa a
revelar-se da ciência começa a existir
pela matemática começa a assistir de
química e então nós fizemos esse projeto
com os anos cerca de mil associados da
entidade é que nos poderiam dar essa
projeção como sem deficiência já estamos
a trabalhar com aveiro como tivemos
também com essa centralização de 120
nova da barquinha é própria sair no frio
já chegou até nós precisamente por este
momento de precisar que é o vai fazer
introduzir a magia nesta nesta situação
e eu queria tenha pensado inicialmente
em trazer aqui o momento em que mostra
como a matemática faz verdadeiramente em
truques de magia
confesso é o trecho a última hora esse
momento porque ela era um pouco
memorável fria
a participação mundial é incrível é que
o público o palco fazer umas contas e
pronto até não é muito bem esta é sua
vertente tanto muricy caiu onde fiquei
por um outro momento continua a
demonstrar é o que é que é macia
eu não falei que
demonstra efetivamente nós temos um
pequeno envelope que tem uma previsão um
número matemático que eu escrevi eu não
sei se vou conseguir ver tanto tem aqui
um pouco limpo o número não se conseguem
ver a essa distância e eu vou guardar
este papel e vou fazer uma previsão que
nós fizemos uma previsão mágica e vou
pedir o senhor por exemplo
sim eu não precisei e não preciso ver
porque não precisa vir não precisa pode
ser lei porque o audrey é que eu nem tem
que vir alguém que eu posso fazer o
truque matemática e outro e que por este
em que pode usar a partir daí o que é
como vai fazer e eu vou explodir vai
dizer o número para que eu tenho é que o
número nesta previsão vai me dizer o
número alguns entrou e 50 mas acho que
tem que observar algumas premissas
esse número tem formato dois organismos
em parte diferente entre si por exemplo
não pode ser o onze mas polícia 17 diga
por favor um número tudo o que pensa que
o craque não 4 é para tem que ser dois
algarismos inpar diferentes entre si
3131 muito bem
lembro que eu tenho aqui um papel com um
número uma previsão deve muitas outras
opções mas disse 31 e retirar o meu
problema
obrigado efetivamente é matemática
quando é aplicada fácil e tecnologia faz
algo diferente por mim fazer e e em ovar
um pouco criar esta actividade dos
jovens promessas ciência que por vezes
não foi preciso porque eu não gosto de
matemática
claro que nós temos essas presas todas é
e com isso conseguimos mostrar os seus
dominar e que os conceitos e depois
saírem da caixa é usar em sua
criatividade e conseguiram ir e fazer
algo diferente
por exemplo eu e tu também tá aqui mais
um momento fácil que é que nós não
falamos só de matemática para engenharia
química e física temos vários exemplos
entramos utilizar a criatividade para
explicar o conceito ciência parece magia
está aqui um exemplo nós falamos em
finais o conceito onde ótica
devemos usar algo tão simples como dois
cartões papel iguais entre si
mas quando nós já fizemos a ok vou
tornar esta melhora para este
empreendimento fica muito melhor e isso
não se consegue ficar na verdade está
apenas uma ilusão de ótica porque
factual são iguais mas podemos também
usar algo muito mais simples toque no
tem duas retas em alguns momentos ele
está alguém para verificar são certas
pintadas que não se deslocam e que tal
em sentidos diferentes mas nós
consideramos isto um magusto excessos
que esta não só acontece com a nota esta
a pontaria imediatamente o processo
formavam um ano antes e 180 graus
mas as duas chatas forrozão se nós nos
colocarmos isto é nossa ilusão
permite-nos fax exceto apontar para o
norte supostamente as lá atrás a
pontaria para baixo
encerrado na verdade ela formou um
ângulo de 90 graus e obviamente
se usar o enem nos permite fazer algo
mais estamos a falar no campo da física
e decisões é que nós fizemos agora
acerta é contar para olavo quando é que
vocês supostamente pensam que o outro
irá apontar a 180 90 40 e 50 fica
exatamente a apontar para o mesmo sítio
e sócios quiserem comprovar no fim é
fácil verificaram que as setas não são
desenhadas aumentos são viáveis não se
deslocam são magnéticas nós colocamos o
erro e elas facto é premente parece que
vão deslocando mas temos mais temos mais
exemplos vejamos alguns exemplos nós
conseguimos continuar a usar esta
criatividade na idéia é passar aos
jovens conceitos conhecimentos da
ciência fazem truques é o desafio é
premente inexplicáveis impossíveis por
exemplo um par os casos como porca algo
que só sairia naturalmente e como o
desafio é com o cara como é que eu
conseguiria desapertar esta coca sem lhe
tocar com as mãos e pra isso eu vou
colocar à venda esta garrafa
garantidamente não vou tocar este
desafio é colocar as crianças eu digo a
única coisa que possa usar o poder da
mente
no sentido figurado e às vezes basta
olhar usa magnética arranja muitas
funções é verdade mas eu quero votar
essa porca em poucos segundos
então os relativamente à ciência o
conhecimento se eu levar a garrafa com
muita cultivada força centrífuga tira
esta peça contra a empresa
o atrito vai desapontar e fazer o nosso
trabalho
isso vai durar quatro horas
mas como nós estamos em um ambiente pecs
e creio que isto seja muito mais rápido
o empreendimento
neste momento podemos dizer é facto
temos a porta retirada do profuso e isto
é a ciência fazer o quase impossível
claro que vemos é ok mas aí não tem mais
dia eu não vou fazer o truque de magia
mas vamos dizer onde a energia que entra
quando nós vivemos em ok e depois fazer
um intervalo a hora do café se quiserem
ver é se nós pegarmos eu tenho agora
três peças três portas três parafusos
cada um com sua cor o desafio é eu
consigo desatar é a porca do parafuso de
cor que alguém me cara colocando os três
casos dentro da ordem que alguém também
indicará não vou fazer agora nós podemos
acompanhar porque o tempo vai correndo
mas fica é promessa
lá fora não durante o café desapontar aí
acordo para fizerem isto é o uso do
conceito ciência é fazer qualquer coisa
na magia e secretaria atividade como faz
distinguir diferenciar a parte esta esta
enfim da ciência o chamado ensino da
ciência não formal vai consumi lá e não
antes pelo contrário
consolidar o fácil enfim da ciência
formal que é fundamental
nós temos que conseguir e conhecer os
conceitos para criar algo diferente se
fora da caixa
eu verifiquei também tem esses três
livros escritos publicados têm mais
críticos salvar o mundo mas futebol não
é segredo da serra de ambientes e nesses
livros o escritor melhor
muitos outros antes pelo contrário
também não consideram o circuito se nós
não conseguirmos ler um livro temos à
frente imediatamente nunca mais
procurando sismos têm tido uma procura
mas o grande elemento diferenciador face
é nas sessões
então eu faço isso de facto o tema
energia e 12 uma magia é alusiva à
história estão envolvidas por exemplo me
pôr em causa tinham salvar o mundo fala
van
brincar com a imaginação esquecer os
telemóveis os playstations os
computadores e brincar com a sua
criatividade é a palavra que atirar nas
crianças costumam dizer é imaginação e
ela está indo e portanto porque o livro
nós criamos momentos de magia que pé
essa brincadeira da imaginação como por
exemplo folhas akira e uma folha caiu um
país porque o menino encontrou aquela
folha super homem em salvar o mundo
mestre carbono um livro que fala
exatamente sobre o aquecimento global é
uma banda tema da química
mas porque é que estou destacar este
facto energia conclui company sonhos
fazem diferenciação e faz a
diferenciação ao ponto de pensar nos
ouvirem falar nós somos aqui o escritor
mas não sou escritora sou mágico também
tem livros e então é com o mestre
carbono
começamos é falar e promover a química
ao ponto sociedade portuguesa de química
nos contactar estamos neste momento
vamos ter a segunda feira em sintra numa
escola promover a química está a ter
quase não procura dos alunos
imagina possa fazer essa diferença o tal
que sim
acabei de enviar casamentos perfeitos
livro de magia e por isso que não vive a
química surgiu naturalmente esposa este
convite nós falaram se do projeto a
química entre nós quando mostramos que o
uso a química porque nós somos feitos
química e então é nós com essa ciência e
energia também conseguimos de alguma
forma promover esta ciência mostrando
que a química está em tudo eu costumo
brincar e dizer certo a mesma fosse
produtos naturais e esta firmeza fosse
produtos químicos toda a gente a nokia
tem mesmo como produto nesta mesa
produto traz um toque terra é um produto
natural por exemplo o cianeto é
perfeitamente natural enquanto aquela
molécula brutal que matou mata milhões
pessoas que é fundamental na indústria
e chama oxi livro gênio é um produto
químico megawatts o plano distante é que
a questão é que alçam químicos e calção
químicos só que os químicos naturais e
os químicos sintéticos e portanto não
temos nunca tive que me interessam os
maus ea cada propósito daquilo que
ouvimos da manhã a química do amor é
mais um projeto que nós só pensava em
salvar as escolas com as por imposição
dos professores porque eu fiz aí está em
jeito de brincadeira nunca foi a
consciência convidaram e nós que foi a
consciência começamos a falar das
substâncias químicas envolvidas por trás
do amor a fase da paixão que falava a
manhã em que nós toda a gente sabe mas
eu queria viver apaixonado para sempre
nada mais errado
de facto nós não temos de ver essa faz
toda por ficarmos todos nós não dormimos
durante a paixão por causa dos crimes
nós mas a natureza é sábia imediatamente
nos envia essas substâncias químicas
quando se acalmaram o amor e por aí fora
e nós nas escolas que é que distingue
não falamos só visto
fazemos magia alusiva isto e tem sido um
sucesso e por isso começamos a sair esta
projeta química do amor e para concluir
rapidamente o facto da magia o portal da
imaginação
nós fazemos a criança mostrar um curto
vídeo já sei que a torcida é ultrapassar
o tempo todo com 10 computadores a vida
importa só para mostrar os factos que
isto conselho não sei se tem que avançar
mais um como esses projetos envolvem
crianças ou adultos conseguem ir
divertir bota é isso é isso seis anos
sem deficiência seja nas escolas seis em
cafés e um liberalismo telemóveis para
os cargos de técnico em espetáculos
montados com as crianças que tiveram a
treinar tudo que é feito de desafios da
ciência toda a gente conhece
é parte do desfile a gravidade em que as
crianças se envolvem em que prende os
conceitos se divertem e se sentem
estrelas no espetáculo montava público
os chamados a filha grávida em que o em
sustentar e água quente aquela bolinha e
parem com as pessoas conseguem estar
livre de haver todo este primeira lei
bonito não se aplicava não com a forma
física mas sim com o ovo é que ir dentro
do copo d'água que nós damos uma pancada
a inércia e faz com que tudo saia chato
ou ficar direito em graças à gravidade
este conceito não sendo espancadas as
crianças em jeito também de oficinas em
jeito espetáculo nós lhe falámos um
pouco aquela ilusão de ótica e esse
aconteceram já viram como funciona como
as crianças se divertem um desafio
atrito em que o mágico consegue que a
garrafa à empresa um panfleto ou um
pauzinho estava ea personagem não
conhece a pessoa foi lá e não consegue
nós conseguimos segurar uma corda numa
garrafa ea pessoa não consegue
nós temos os dedos mágicos não nós temos
o segredo a ciência nos ensina a fazer
isto
todas estas preta aparenta pelo menos aí
amarelo tá escondido até para criar o o
fascínio ea destruição também faz parte
[Música]
e então muito bom em matemática um forte
matemática em fio mágico sabe exatamente
qual é o seu voto vai lá ficar
estando costas voltadas ea pessoa pode
movimentar os envelopes com sempre
fizeram mas como eu sei onde estão os
shows começam ser matematicamente ainda
não vai estar lá escrito é que o fizeram
inclusive me instalar um símbolo vai
produzir um peixinho uma maneira mágica
isso cria o fascínio o tal julgamento
que a palavra chave de toda espécie
para isso a bandidagem momento de
diversão nas zonas ciência está
normalmente e apresentava em powerpoint
trás pode fazer pensar e pensar que é
que estou a ver que estava baseado no
conceito está aflito trás
quem consegue aprender ciência divertida
terminando assim e obrigado
[Aplausos]